if you are dating someone who refuses to share locations with you
what are you doing?
some people are like oh
“that's an invasion of privacy”
“I don't want people to check in on me”
why?? what are you doing?
like my friends and family all have my location and I have theirs
it's usually for safety and also curiosity
but it's fine they do the same thing
sometimes it's just for fun to check in on them
but what are you doing that you don't want them to have your location?
I want the people I love to know that I'm safe
The only times I have concerns about sharing my locations with my husband
is when I'm going to target or Homegoods for the third time this week
but other than that I genuinely cannot think of a reason
why I would not wanna share my location with my partner
like unless you're doing something shady
that is the only thing I can think of
I know so many people are torn on this
but if you don't want your location shared why?
What’s the reason.. and make it a good one.
because it literally does not make sense to me.